time so we intend to be very responsive
and we're going to take you live now
back to the Senate hearing Chairman
Bernanke entering the road in this white
and block without opening statements how
will I do by full statement where the
record Center to [ __ ] do you have
anything to add no mr. chairman a letter
my records state my statement for the
record as well we will allow both to
report the nominations of dr. Jason
Furman to be a member and chairman of
the Council of Economic Advisers miss
Kara Stein to be a member of the SEC dr.
mercola vivar to be a member of the SEC
that honorable richard Metzger to be a
member of the NCUA board and the
Honorable married to Hoyt for a second
term as a member of the SEC exploring on
jun 5 2013 favor say aye aye those
opposed say nay eyes have it the
nominations are here burp reported
favorably to the full Senate we will now
consider congressman's wats nomination
to head the FHFA congressman what has
over 40 years of experience in housing
real estate and other financial service
issues as an attorney and member of the
House Financial Services Committee in
his 20-plus years practicing law he has
personally walked hundreds of families
through real estate closings this is the
kind of in-depth expertise we need
leading the FHFA so our urge my
colleagues to join me in voting for
congressman wats nomination senator
Crapo would you'd like to make a brief
statement yes mr. chairman thank you and
I'm pleased that we were able to move
the initial group of nominees by a voice
vote today I congratulate each of them
and wish them a
speedy confirmation process on the floor
a representative wat has had a long
distinguished career in the House of
Representatives and in legal practice
he's well liked by his colleagues
regardless of whether they see
eye-to-eye with him on the issues his
personal story is compelling at every
level and I believe he could have easily
won confirmation with broad bipartisan
support for a number of cabinet and
presidential advisor positions open at
the time of his nomination however this
position is like no other position in
our government as conservator this
nominee would actually operate Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac whose combined
portfolios exceed five trillion dollars
in fact if confirmed this nominee would
stand alone as regulator operator and
shareholder of Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac because the conservator has
virtually unchecked power to control to
multi-trillion dollar companies and
through them our entire mortgage market
the conservator must be an apolitical
financial regulator with technical
expertise and someone who will resist
political pressure from all sides of the
political spectrum additionally the
conservator must possess an in-depth
knowledge of the operations of the
mortgage industry the mortgage-backed
security industry structured
securitisations investment portfolios
the operations of both public and
private insurance and guarantees and the
expertise to oversee the nearly 12,000
employees employed by both entities the
white house was fully aware of all of
these concerns however rather than
acknowledging the unique aspects of the
job the white house chose to ignore
these calls that they emphasized
technical expertise and political
independence in their search I'm
disappointed with that decision and
forcing us today into the position we
find ourselves as I evaluate the unique
powers and responsibilities of the
conservator I cannot support
representative wat to fill that position
and must also urge my colleagues to
oppose his nomination Thank You mr.
chairman what any other members like to
make a brief statement will allow have a
roll call vote and Congressman what to
be a director of the FHFA the clerk will
call the roll
hi hi hi bear proxy I / proxy I propoxy
no no by proxy
mr. Parker
mr. bittre no by proxy no by proxy mr.
Tierney no mr. car Noah by proxy no by
proxy mr. cutter no no by proxy
rights have it the nominations are here
were reported favorably to the full
Senate mr. Chairman I senator Brown
thank you Miss German I would like to
just take 30 seconds to address the to
address the light the nomination of Mary
Jo white I i voted against ms white in
march at the time i said i hope she
proves me wrong unfortunately at this
point I've your record is more negative
than positive she's not yet met the
burden of proof to change my mind for
that reason my position has not changed
but I hope again I hope that it will
anywhere where has seven days to enter a
statement into the record that before we
turn to our hearing would anyone else
like to make a brief statement on any
the nominations the executive session is
concluded and we will proceed to your
circle monetary policy hearing
thank you
good morning I call this here in the
order today would welcome chairman
bernanke back to the committee to
deliver the Federal Reserve's
semi-annual monetary policy report
nearly five years after the worst
financial crisis since the Great
Depression the US economy continues to
show signs of improvement recently we
have seen the housing market
strengthened and payroll employment form
of private sector job growth strengthen
this year to around 200,000 jobs per
month the economy has shown signs of
resilience despite fiscal tightening on
housing I'm pleased to see that the
recovery is gaining momentum with solid
home price gains nationwide new home
construction has seen double-digit
growth and single-family home sales have
also picked up many homeowners remain
underwater but overall numbers continue
to decline going forward I would
encourage the Fed to be thoughtful in
its actions to make sure these positive
trends in housing continue Congress has
a role to play to to address fha's
short-term challenges breaking member
crapo and I release details this week a
bipartisan legislation to get FHA back
unstable footing and circular a program
important to many Americans fall in this
effort will turn to comprehensive
housing finance reform legislation much
progress has been made but the labor
market has not fully recovered from the
Great Recession what were force
participation remains low even one
accounting for retiring baby boomers and
long-term unemployment remains near hers
is newer historic levels moreover
youth unemployment green means hi in
even many young college graduates
struggled to find gainful employment
these trends have lessened effects on
the economy over the long longer term
still erosion from prolonged
unemployment would reduce our economy's
potential it is important that we help
not hurt young Americans prospects and
why it is so important that Congress
finds a reasonable solution to the
recent increase in student loan rates to
fulfill is dominate the Fed should not
prematurely step on their brakes with
consumer price inflation law and there
an unemployment rate unacceptably high
the Fed must continue to take action to
support employment when the time comes
it is important that monetary policy
adjustments are gradual and do not
disrupt financial stability and economic
economic growth Chairman Bernanke I
thank you for your years of service and
leadership at the Federal Reserve in a
challenging period in our nation's
history and I look forward to hearing
testimony I now turn to ranking member
purple thank you very much mr. chairman
and Chairman Bernanke welcome I welcome
our federal reserve chairman ben
bernanke back to the banking committee
to testify at the semi-annual
humphrey-hawkins hearing regarding the
Federal Reserve's monetary policy and
the state of the economy in recent weeks
the Prudential banking regulators have
been very active on a number of
regulatory fronts including releasing
final regulations to implement the Basel
3 capital rules and proposed regulations
on capital leverage ratios I thank
chairman bernanke personally for
addressing the concerns that chairman
Johnson and I raised in our februari
letter about the unique characteristics
of community banks and insurance
companies a one-size-fits-all approach
regarding capital rules does not work
for these types of entities
with regard to monetary policy we've
experienced a period where the Fed has
pushed the short-term interest rate down
to zero more than four years ago the Fed
pursued quantitative easing or what's
become known as QE in order to suppress
long-term interest rates as a result the
fed's balance sheet now stands at nearly
3.5 trillion dollars with an additional
85 billion dollars every month in
long-term assets being added recently
released FOMC minutes from the June
meeting indicate that several members of
the board felt that a reduction in asset
purchases would likely soon be warranted
several noted economists have called
into question whether the benefits of
these purchases outweigh the risks the
negative reaction by equity markets to
the June FOMC statement on tapering
indicates that some indicates that some
of the increase in the prices of
equities and other assets recently is
attributable to the fed's balance sheet
expansion and not to purely economic
fundamentals in fact June marked the
worst month on record for bond fund
outflows the reaction indicates that
markets are still heavily reliant on
government intervention which is not
good for the long-term health of the
economy I'm interested to hear from
Chairman Bernanke to what extent the Fed
anticipates the inevitable tapering
process will cause in terms of
additional periods of market volatility
because of the official stance of the
Fed is that the decision to taper
remains data-dependent I'm interested in
hearing if the Chairman believes laying
out specific data would improve both the
feds commitment to the policy and the
market's reaction to it beyond tapering
which is simply slowing the rate of
growth of the fed's balance sheet is the
more important issue of winding down the
feds massive balance sheet the Fed has
indicated that it may continue to roll
over its holdings of long term assets
which means that its balance sheet may
not shrink for some time a key element
of the exit strategy adopted by the FOMC
in June of 2011 is a three to five year
period over which the Fed expected that
it could completely eliminate its
holdings of agency securities this was
done for the purpose of minimizing the
to which the agency securities portfolio
might affect the allocation of credit
across sectors of the economy since then
the balance sheet has increased in size
by more than twenty percent to as I said
almost 3.5 trillion dollars and the feds
holding of agency securities has
increased by more than thirty percent to
about 1.2 trillion dollars why does the
Fed see the need for such accommodative
policy to continue into the future in
light of the feds large portfolio
increases the dominant role that the
GSEs play in today's mortgage market and
the recent increases in the level and
volatility of mortgage rates will the
Fed revise its balance sheet exit
strategy principles in particular will
the Fed be revising the time period over
which it expects to eliminate its
holdings of agency securities it's my
hope that this hearing gives us
additional insight into the feds plans
for the future reduction of asset
purchases and a roadmap for a return to
normalized rules based monetary policy
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You senator
Crapo to preserve time for questions
opening statements will be limited to
the chair and American member i would
like to remind my colleagues that the
record will be open for the next seven
days for additional statements and any
other materials I'd like to welcome
Chairman Bernanke dr. Bernanke is
currently serving a second term as
chairman of the board of governors of
the Federal Reserve System his first
term began under President Bush and 2006
before that Tector p'naki was chairman
of the Council of Economic Advisers and
served as a member of the board of
governors of the Federal Reserve System
Chairman Bernanke please begin your
testimony Thank You mr. chairman ranking
member crapo and other members of the
committee i'm pleased to present the
Federal Reserve semiannual monetary
policy report to the Congress in my
brief remarks I'll discuss current
economic conditions and the outlook and
then turn to monetary policy and I'll
finish with a short summary of our
ongoing work on regulatory reform
with respect to the outlook the economic
recovery has continued at a moderate
pace in recent quarters despite the
strong headwinds created by federal
fiscal policy housing has contributed
significantly to recent gains in
economic activity home sales house
prices and residential construction have
moved up over the past year supported by
low mortgage rates and improves
confidence in both the housing market
and the economy rising housing
construction and home sales are adding
to job growth and substantial increases
in home prices are bolstering household
finances and consumer spending while
reducing the number of homeowners with
underwater mortgages housing activity
and prices seem likely to continue to
recover notwithstanding the recent
increases in mortgage rates but it will
be important to monitor developments in
this sector carefully conditions in the
labor market are improving gradually the
unemployment rate stood at 7.6 percent
in June about a half percentage point
lower than in the months before the
Federal Open Market Committee initiated
its current asset purchase program in
September non-farm payroll employment
has increased by an average of about
200,000 jobs per month so far this year
despite these gains the job situation is
far from satisfactory as the
unemployment rate remains well above its
longer-run normal level and rates of
underemployment and long-term
unemployment are still much too high
meanwhile consumer price inflation has
been running below the committee's
longer-run objective of 2% the price
index or personal consumption
expenditures rose only one percent over
the year ending in May this softness
reflects in part some factors that are
likely to be transitory moreover
measures of longer-term inflation
expectations have generally remained
stable which should help move inflation
back up toward 2% however the committee
is certainly aware that very low
inflation poses risks to economic
performance for example by raising the
real cost of capital investment and
increases the risk of outright deflation
consequently we will monitor this
situation closely as well and we will
act as needed to ensure that inflation
moves back toward our 2% objective
overtime at the June FOMC meeting my
colleagues and I projected that economic
growth would pick up in coming quarters
resulting in gradual progress towards
the levels of unemployment and inflation
consistent with the Federal Reserve
statutory mandate to foster maximum
employment and price stability
specifically most participants are real
GDP growth beginning to step up during
the second half of this year eventually
reaching a paste between two point nine
and three point six percent in 2015 they
projected the unemployment rate to
decline to between 5.8 and 6.2 percent
by the final quarter of 2015 and they
saw inflation gradually increasing
toward the committee's 2% objective the
pickup in economic growth projected by
most committee participants partly
reflects their view that federal fiscal
policy will exert somewhat less drag
over time as the effects of the tax
increases and the spending sequestration
diminished the committee also believes
that risk to the economy have diminished
since the fall reflecting some easing of
financial stresses in Europe the gains
and housing and labor markets that I
mentioned earlier the better budgetary
positions of state and local governments
and stronger household and business
balance sheets that said the risk
remained a tight federal fiscal policy
will restrain economic growth over the
next few quarters by more than we
currently expect or that the debate
concerning other fiscal policy issues
such as the status of the debt ceiling
will evolve in a way that could hamper
recovery more generally with the
recovery still proceeding and only a
moderate pace the economy remains
vulnerable to unanticipated shocks
including the possibility the global
economic growth may be slower than
currently anticipated with unemployment
still high in declining only gradually
and without inflation running below the
committee's longer-run objective a
highly accommodative monetary policy
will remain appropriate for the
foreseeable future in normal
circumstances the committee's basic tool
for providing monetary accommodation is
its target for the federal funds rate
however the target range for the federal
funds rate has been close to zero since
late 2008 and cannot be reduced
meaningfully further instead we are
providing additional policy
accommodation through two distinct yet
complementary policy tools the first
tool is expanding the Federal Reserve's
portfolio of longer-term
suree Securities and agency
mortgage-backed securities we are
currently purchasing forty billion
dollars per month in agency MBS and 45
billion dollars per month in Treasuries
the second tool is forward guidance
about the committee's plans for setting
the federal funds rate target over the
medium term within our overall policy
framework we think of these tools as
having somewhat different roles we are
using asset purchases and the resulting
expansion of the Federal Reserve's
balance sheet primarily to increase the
near-term momentum of the economy with a
specific goal of achieving a substantial
improvement in the outlook for the labor
market in a context of price stability
we've made some progress toward this
goal and with inflation subdued we
intend to continue our purchases until a
substantial improvement in the labor
market outlook has been realized in
addition even after purchases n the
Federal Reserve will be holding its
stock of Treasury and agency securities
off the market and we investing the
proceeds for maturing securities which
will continue to put downward pressure
on longer-term interest rates support
mortgage markets and help to make
broader financial conditions more
accommodative we are relying on near 0
short-term interest rates together with
our forward guidance that rates will
continue to be exceptionally low this is
our second tool to help maintain a high
degree of monetary accommodation for an
extended period after asset purchases
end even as the economic recovery
strengthens and unemployment declines
towards more normal levels an
appropriate combination these two tools
can provide the high level of policy
accommodation needed to promote a
stronger economic recovery with price
stability in the interest of
transparency committee participants
agreed in June that it would be helpful
to lay out more details about our
thinking regarding the asset purchase
program specifically to provide
additional information on our assessment
of progress to date as well as of the
likely trajectory of the program if the
economy evolves is projected this
agreement to provide additional
information did not reflect a change in
policy the committee's decisions
regarding the asset purchase program and
the overall stance of monetary policy
depend on our assessment of the economic
outlook and of the cumulative progress
toward our objectives of course economic
forecasts no
be revised when new information arrives
and thus are necessarily provisional as
I noted the economic outcomes that the
committee participants saw is most
likely in their June projections involve
continuing gains and labor markets
supported by moderate growth that picks
up over the next several quarters as the
restraint from fiscal policy diminishes
committee participants also saw
inflation moving back toward our two
percent objective over time if the
incoming data were to be broadly
consistent with these projections we
anticipated that it would be appropriate
to begin to moderate the monthly pace of
purchases later this year and if the
subsequent data can continue to confirm
this pattern of ongoing economic
improvement and normalizing inflation we
expected to continue to reduce the pace
of purchases and measured steps through
the first half of next year ending them
around mid-year at that point if the
economy had evolved along the lines we
anticipated the recovery would have
gained further momentum unemployment
would be in the vicinity of seven
percent and inflation would be moving
toward our two percent objective such
outcomes would be fully consistent with
the goals of the asset purchase program
that we established in September I
emphasize that because our asset
purchases depend on economic and
financial developments they are by no
means on a preset course on the one hand
if economic conditions were to improve
faster than expected and inflation
appeared to be rising decisively back
toward our objective the pace of asset
purchases could be reduced somewhat more
quickly on the other hand if the outlook
for employment were to become relatively
less favorable if inflation did not
appear to be moving back toward 2% or
financial conditions which have
tightened recently were judged to be
insufficiently accommodative to allow us
to attain our mandated objectives the
current pace of purchases could be
maintained for longer indeed if needed
the committee would be prepared to
employ all of its tools including an
increase in the pace of purchases for a
time to promote a return to maximum
employment in the context of price
stability as I noted the second tool the
committee is using to support the
recovery is forward guidance regarding
the path of the federal funds rate the
committee has said it intends to
maintain a high degree of monetary
accommodation for considerable time
after the
asset purchase program ends and the
economic recovery strengthens in
particular the committee anticipates
that its current exceptionally low
target range for the federal funds rate
will be appropriate at least as long as
the unemployment rate remains above six
and a half percent and inflation and
inflation expectations remain well
behaved in the sense described in the
FOMC statement as I have observed on
several occasions the phrase at least as
long as is a key component of the policy
rate guidance these words indicate that
the specific numbers for unemployment
and inflation in the guidance our
thresholds not triggers reaching one of
the thresholds would not automatically
result in an increase in the federal
funds rate target rather it would lead
the committee to consider whether the
outlook for the labor market inflation
and the broader economy justified such
an increase for example of a substantial
part of the reductions and measured
unemployment were judged to reflect
cyclical declines labor force
participation rather than gains in
employment the committee would be
unlikely to view a decline in
unemployment to six and a half percent
as a sufficient reason to raise its
target for the federal funds rate
likewise the committee would be unlikely
to raise the funds rate if inflation
remained persistently below our
longer-run objective moreover so long as
the economy remains short of maximum
employment inflation remains nearer
longer-run objective and inflation
expectations remain well anchored
increases in the target for the federal
funds rate once they begin are likely to
be gradual let me finish by providing
you with a brief update on progress on
reforms to reduce the systemic risk at
our largest financial firms as governor
Tarullo discussed in his testimony last
week before this committee the Federal
Reserve with the other federal banking
agencies adopted a final rule earlier
this month to implement the Basel 3
capital reforms the final rule increases
the quantity and quality of required
regulatory capital by establishing a new
minimum common equity tier 1 capital
ratio and implementing a capital
conservation buffer the rule also
contains a supplementary leverage ratio
and account of cyclical capital buffer
that apply only to large and
internationally active banking
organizations consistent with their
systemic importance in addition the
Federal Reserve will
capital surcharges on firms opposed the
greatest systemic risk and will issue a
proposal to implement the Basel 3
quantitative liquidity requirements as
they are phased in over the next few
years the Federal Reserve is considering
further measures to strengthen the
capital positions of large
internationally active banks including
the proposed rule issued last week that
would increase the required leverage
ratios for such firms the Fed also is
working to finalize the enhanced
prudential standards set out in sections
165 and 166 of the dodd-frank act among
these standards rules relating the
stress testing and resolution planning
already are in place and we have been
actively engaged in stress tests and
reviewing the first wave resolution
plans in coordination with other
agencies we've made significant progress
on the key substantive issues relating
to the Volcker Rule and are hoping to
complete it by year-end finally the
Federal Reserve is preparing to regulate
and supervise systemically important
non-bank financial firms last week the
financial stability Oversight Council
designated to non-bank financial firms
it has proposed the designation of a
third firm which has requested a hearing
before the council we are developing a
supervisory and regulatory framework
that can be tailored to each firms
business mix risk profile and systemic
footprint consistent with the Collins
Amendment and other legal requirements
under the dodd-frank act thank you and
be pleased to take your questions Thank
You chairman bernanke as we put in
questions i will isaac or to put five
minutes on the clock for each member
Chairman Bernanke with inflation low and
unemployment so high what trends in the
data would you need to see before
deciding to begin unwinding monetary
policy measures would unwinding too
early threaten economy and the financial
system well certainly we face the same
issues that are always faced with
monetary policy begins to normalize
after a period of recession and
expansion which is if we tighten too
soon we risk
not letting the economy get back to full
employment if we tighten too late we
risk having some inflation so as always
there going to be issues of judgement
there that are unavoidable in any
monetary policy normalization that being
said we have laid out essentially a
three-stage process for our
normalization the first which is
dependent on the economy strengthening
the labor market continuing to normalize
and inflation beginning to move back
towards 2% is a process of slowing
moderating the pace of our asset
purchases and eventually bringing those
20 additional purchases at the point
that we can say that we've made
substantial improvement in the outlook
for the labor market and we've given
some guidelines about how that process
would go forward the second stage would
be a potentially lengthy period in which
we are watching the economy for
continued improvement continue to
reduction in unemployment normalization
of inflation as I described in my
testimony when unemployment gets the 6.5
percent and not before and when
inflation is looking closer to target at
that point we would consider whether
tightening in in the form of raising
short-term interest rates is appropriate
so that would be the second stage the
final stage would be ultimate
normalization of policy the the raising
of short-term interest rates and
eventually the normalization of our
balance sheet as I noted in my in my
testimony assuming that the economy
remains in a slow growth mode as we've
been seeing that that process would be
very gradual process what explains the
reason prize and long-term interest
rates and how much more of an increase
in rates could cause a recovery to
falter and what would the Federal
Reserve do to respond if interest rates
spike well there are essentially three
reasons why we've seen some increase in
longer term rates although I would
emphasize they remain relatively low the
first is that there's been some better
economic new
as investors see brighter prospects
ahead interest rates tend to rise for
example we saw a relatively good labor
market report which was accompanied by
pretty sharp increase in interest rates
on that day a second reason for the
increase in rates is probably the
unwinding of leveraged and perhaps
excessively risky positions in the
market it's probably a good thing to
have that happen although the tightening
that's associated with that is unwelcome
but at least the benefit of it is that
some concerns about building financial
risks are mitigated in that way and
probably make some FOMC participants
more comfortable with using this tool
going forward the third reason for the
increase in races has to do with Federal
Reserve communications and and market
interpretations of Fed policy we've
tried to be very clear from the
beginning and I've reiterated again
today that we have not changed policy we
are not talking about tightening
monetary policy merely we've been trying
to lay out the same sequence which I
just described to you about how we're
going to move going forward and how that
will be tied to the economy but I want
to emphasize that none of that implies
that monetary policy will be tighter at
any time within the foreseeable future
would you currently see as the biggest
threat to the housing market recovery as
we continue housing finance reform well
certainly we have to keep our eye open
open to pay attention to mortgage rates
and affordability that's that's our job
it's a Fed but I think it's very
important for us to get our housing
institutions our regulatory structure to
get those cleared up to get those in
working order I'm glad to see that the
Congress is now looking at reforms of
the Fannie and Freddie the mortgage
securitization system we still have
rules to do about skin in the game and
other aspects of
the mortgage market I think as is
greater clarity about the rules of the
game for mortgage making and mortgage
securitization that we will see less
tightness in the market for mortgages
for first-time homebuyers and people
with less than perfect credit scores and
I think one of the risks that we face
now is that there is still a pretty
significant part of the population that
is having considerable difficulty
accessing mortgage credit even though
they may have the financial wherewithal
to to be worthy of that credit senator
[ __ ] Thank You mr. chairman and
Chairman Bernanke you've previously
indicated that the Fed wants to see
substantial improvement in the labor
market before cutting off QE and in your
June press conference you noted that
substantial is in the eye of the
beholder if I understood you today you
indicated that it all goes as expected
we could expect to see this wound down
completely by mid-year next year is that
correct if if all goes as expected yes
and I guess the the flip side of that is
you said if all does not go as expected
we could see QE continued for the
indefinite future I suspect that at some
point that the economy will will reach
that substantial improvement in the
outlook given the way we've seen
progress to this point exactly whether
it's a little bit later a little bit
earlier that that remains to be seen I
guess my question is I assume you would
agree that there is risk in continuing
QE indefinitely would you agree with
that yes there are costs and risks to QE
and we are watching those carefully
we've said in our statement that one of
the considerations that we're looking at
at every meeting is the efficiency and
costs of this of this program and we do
a benefit cost analysis as we discuss
the benefits and of additional purchases
well given the notion that substantial
is really in the eye of the beholder I
don't think it's very easy for the
markets to understand exactly how and
when we are going to see the winding
down
curr and to me it appears that possibly
communicating more specific targets
rather than thresholds would help to
reduce that risk do you agree or do you
think it's just not possible to get more
specific well this is an issue that the
committee will continue to discuss I
would say first that we have given some
fairly specific qualitative guidance
about what we're looking for and I did
say that unemployment in the general
vicinity of seven percent with inflation
moving back towards this two percent
objective was indicative of the kind of
progress that we were trying to achieve
the thresholds are tied to rate
increases and they're while reaching
that threshold doesn't necessarily mean
it will raise rates we are quite
confident that we will not raise rates
before we get to those points in that
sense we're providing a reassurance to
the public into the markets thank you
with regard to winding down the fed's
balance sheet you and others have
indicated a willingness to keep the
fed's QE securities on the balance sheet
rolling over maturing securities and
keeping them out of the market governor
Tarullo said on Monday that no one is
talking about unwinding or selling the
securities we've been buying which would
mean then that the fed's balance sheet
could be over three trillion dollars for
some time correct well not necessarily
because of course these ultimately we
will stop ultimately we will stop
rolling over and reinvesting the
Securities and then they'll begin to run
off and then the balance sheet will
start to come down we have we have done
a lot of scenario analysis of course and
allowing the securities to run off at a
certain point when the economy is strong
enough does not delay normalization by
very much but you're not expecting the
winding down of the balance sheet at
anytime soon is that certainly not until
we get to the to the rate increase part
of the three point three part sequence
that I described to you and and there
again it would be not we're not planning
at this point
ambs we what we would be doing would be
allowing at some point we would be
allowing the maturing securities just to
run off and not replacing them but as
long as you continue to hold and not
wind down the balance sheet doesn't this
lead to credit miss pricing and
increased investor risk undertaking I I
don't think so particularly when we're
winding down the I don't see that
there's any real difference between for
example are holding mortgage-backed
securities which is intended to
strengthen the housing market and usual
monetary policy which lowers long-term
interest rates through short-term rate
cuts which is also intended to
strengthen the housing market the
housing market is always an important
channel of monetary policy and so I
don't really see that there's any
significant misallocation going on there
all right thank you senator Menendez
thank you Miss cherry Karen Burnett I
understand this may be your final
monetary policy report hearing before
the committee before the end of your
term is chairman of the Federal Reserve
and I'm sure you'll miss us but I want
to thank you for your hard work and
dedication and your service to our
country especially during a a time of
crisis and I appreciate your service we
seem to be experiencing a trend right
now where our economy and employment are
growing and recovering but we still have
from my perspective of ways to dig
ourselves out from the deep hole caused
by the financial crisis unemployment's
coming down but it's still seven point
six percent more than a third of the
people who are unemployed a long-term
unemployed which is a true crisis for
those more than four million individuals
and families caught in this situation
and as you've discussed with this
committee in the past long-term
unemployment can have serious
consequences making harder for people to
maintain skills and networks to re-enter
the workforce so my question is while
the
he is recovering we still have a lot of
work to do to get full employment and
strong broad-based growth with core
inflation well below the feds target and
weak demand suggesting that inflation is
unlikely to be a problem anytime soon
isn't it still way too soon to consider
any kind of policy tightening well again
I've distinguished between changing the
mix of our two tools and the overall
thrust of monetary policy and I agree
with you that with inflation below
target and with unemployment still quite
high and by some measures with
unemployment in some ways being even too
optimistic a measure of the state of the
labor market given some of the other
statistics that you cited that both
sides of our statutory mandate are
suggesting that we need to maintain a
highly accommodative monetary policy for
the foreseeable future and that's what
we intend to do but I think that we will
be able to maintain that high level of
accommodation ultimately through rate
policy and you know and by holding a
very large balance sheet and but in in
making that transition to a different
stage of this process we again are
intending to key policy highly
accommodative let me just follow up as
the Reserve has engaged in measures to
strengthen our economy as some critics
have argued that any growth that results
might somehow be artificial or that low
interest rates and cheaper credit might
lead to financial instability or asset
bubbles if investors make riskier
investment in order to quote reach for
the yield in the current environment
though isn't weak demand the greater
concern if consumers are pulling back on
their spending because of high debt
burdens and underwater mortgages from
the financial crisis and businesses are
holding off on investing because of the
weaker consumer demand doesn't that
change the relative cost benefits and
risks of different monetary policy
actions yes it can on the first point
about artificial growth there
the 30s there was this view called
liquidation estuve you which held that
recessions and depressions were healthy
they purge the evils out of the system I
don't think we accept that point of view
anymore we think our economy is
producing below its potential and what
monetary policy is trying to do is help
the economy return to its potential and
that would be real and sustainable
growth that we could achieve financial
stability there are the obviously given
recent experience we want to be very
careful that we understand what's going
on and pay close attention to these
issues the relationship between monetary
policy and financial stability is a
complicated one on the one hand a very
low rates for sustained period can lead
to reach for yield and other risky
behavior we are trying to address that
primarily through regulation through
oversight through monitoring and that's
our first line of defense certainly for
dealing with those sorts of issues but
you correctly point out that it is a
simple relationship because of course a
weak economy also is bad for financial
stability because it means weaker credit
quality less lending opportunities more
defaults and delinquencies so again our
strategy is to try to focus on inflation
and unemployment using monetary policy
but to pay close attention to any
developments in the financial stability
sphere and use the regulatory and
supervisory tools we have as the first
line of defense in that case I
appreciate them the reason I those
specific questions is because there's
been a great deal written and said about
expansionary of austerity and as I look
at what is happening in Europe I'm not
sure that all the measures taken under
that guy's produce either the economic
results that we'd like to see and
certainly the consequential human
results that we have seen in Europe and
I I don't want us making those mistakes
here Thank You mr. senator Crooker Thank
You mr. chairman and mr. chairman thank
you for being here these that we were
just talking these second day these
humphrey-hawkins meeting is about like
drinking dale coffee and maybe even
worse
accompanied by a stale donut but
certainly i'm here today I don't really
have any questions I read your testimony
yesterday but really to thank you for
your service I know we've had our
differences on some issues but I really
do especially appreciate the way you
handled the crisis I think that our
country was under extreme duress I don't
know how many people could have handled
that crisis and the complexities that
came with it and the way that you did so
I want to thank you for that thank you
obviously we've had discussions both
publicly and privately about some of the
quantitative easing and I know we had
differences but I I would wonder I know
that you know there's a whole industry
of folks out there who watch every word
that you say and people right now doing
calculations as a as to whether to buy
this interest instrumental that and I
know that you have to be very cautious
and what you say sometimes but this is a
little bit of a step back I guess you
know some of the concerns that I've had
and I think members on this side of the
Dyess have just been the hyperactivity
of the of the fed and and the Fed almost
acting as an enabler for Congress which
has had very bad behavior for a long
time our inability to do things fiscally
and in other ways that would stimulate
our economy and I think you're well
aware of those you'd a pretty decent job
of staying away from that although
sometimes i wish you'd weigh in more but
i do wonder if you have any possibly
parting comments i don't know what your
future is and none of us do at this
moment but i wonder if you have any
comments about that about any concerns
about over time because of the
hyperactivity that the fed has been
engaged in and in some ways because
Congress has been so feckless and living
up to its responsibilities and dealing
with the issues that we have to deal
with if that is of any concern to you
and as they're in
similarities if you will to a person who
knows that they need to do certain
things to eat right and exercise and
instead you know relying on the Fed from
Fatima amphetamines and other kinds of
activities to get into place that the
economy needs to be in our nation and
candidly the world but again as you
potentially contemplate those I do one
again thank you for your service thank
you for your friendship and and whatever
happens I wish you well thank you very
much for those comments senator on
hyperactivity I think what we learned
during the crisis was that we didn't
have the right tools you know we didn't
have a way to address a failing
investment bank with that wouldn't
create a huge amount of bad effects in
financial markets we didn't have
appropriate oversight of the shadow
banking system there are a lot of
weaknesses in our oversight or
regulatory system and our response tools
to the crisis and that's why it's
sometimes seem frenetic because the Fed
was trying to improvise in many cases
and I think we've made some progress and
setting up a more orderly framework for
both strengthening our financial system
monitoring the system and responding in
case of another emergency so I hope that
that's the case on it is true that a
monetary policy I think has carried an
awful lot of the burden for this
recovery and you know we more than happy
to share that burden more more equally
with fiscal policy and other
policymakers but I recognize it's been a
difficult time politically for people to
come to agreement on some very important
issues and I don't think you mentioned
the enabler idea I don't think it's my
place or the Federal Reserve's place to
try to force Congress to come to any
particular outcome it's congress is is
ultimately who is responsible and and
our our role is to take what Congress
does is given and to try to figure out
how best to meet our mandate given
Congress's actions I don't think we
should be in a position of trying to
threaten Congress with you know higher
interest rates or something like that
yeah not
I know that's not your place and I know
that you operate under our mandates I
would think though that most people
would ration that you know the fact that
that the fed is there and does have to
do what it does in some ways acts as a
cover for us in our ability to act
responsibly I mean I think that goes
without saying doesn't it well I think
as you can see that are acting alone is
not producing the kind of results we all
would like I mean growth is going in the
right direction unemployment school in
the right direction but it's still a
very slow process and as I've said many
times monetary policy is not a panacea
so there's still plenty of room for
Congress to address some of these
problems that Senator Menendez and
others referred to thank you Thank You
senator to read I thank you very much
mr. chairman and let me join senator
corker mr. chairman and commend you and
thank you for your service to the nation
I witnessed your innovative
improvisational and very thoughtful
approach to problems that were
potentially devastating the economy I
think through your service we avoided a
much worse situation but and I thank you
for that one of the things reflecting
back though is you know to twenty-twenty
hindsight there were a few governors of
the Fed who were talking about a housing
bubble as the next sort of great crisis
but it didn't get the traction perhaps
not identically but in a similar vein
you've got some of your colleagues and
now talking about the huge growing
student debt that is the could have
macroeconomic effects slowing down home
purchases slowing down sort of what we
assume was the normal course that by
your late 20s you buy the home you
settle down etc and also I think in a
way underscoring another huge problem in
the economy which is the inequality
growing inequality of income you know
are sort of American solution to
inequality is
asian that's the engine we have reports
for example from Georgetown University
that there's already a five million
project a gap between jobs available
that will be there and skills available
to film them and yet as we increase the
course borrowing and all the proposals
that we're talking about currently do
increase the course that I think will
cut down on opportunities for a lot of
people so can you comment one on this
potential sort of crisis and student
debt its macroeconomic effects and
whether if we don't provide some type of
support both directly and also
refinancing support that this could be
the next big problem we face well first
it should be acknowledged that the
ability to borrow to build your own
human capital to get an education is
extremely important and good thing you
know there was a time when poor student
no matter how qualified was unable to
finance an education in the fact that we
now can do that is very good for our
economy as well as for individuals the
amount of student debt is is large it's
over a trillion dollars at this point I
think that it is not particularly likely
to cause any sharp instability of the
sort we saw in last few years it has a
couple of consequences one of course is
it represents a potential fiscal risk
for the US government to the extent that
some of it is not repaid secondly to the
extent that there are people who have
taken out a lot of debt and the economy
is not serving them well they're not
finding opportunities then obviously
over time this is not something that is
a big issue at any given moment but over
a number of years they will not be able
to buy the home or do other things that
they otherwise would be able to because
they're paying off the debt so I think
the answer to it is first of course to
have a strong economy that provides job
opportunities and that's something we're
trying to do and I'm sure you're trying
to do as well but the other is I think
we need to make sure that students are
better informed about the market labor
market and their opportunities and what
different
they have you know we know of cases
certain you know some of the private
sector University's online universities
and so on which don't have very good
graduation or placement rates people are
still borrowing to take those courses I
think if there was better counseling
better information that would certainly
be an important step but I don't want us
to step back from doing everything we
can to give young people a chance to get
whatever skills that you know are
appropriate let me just the broader
question was just this your comment this
growing documented inequality and income
in the United States does it pose both
economic and social risks of the country
and how do we deal with it other than
through education and in many different
ways it's a very very tough problem it's
not restricted to the United States it's
a it's a global phenomenon it's been
going on for a very long time there are
a number of factors behind it I think
though that one of the most important is
that the new technologies we're seeing
are what's called skill bias that they
they favor the most skilled workers and
they reduce opportunities for people of
medium or low skills particularly in
competition with the global labor force
so I don't have an easy answer I do
think that related to your question
about student debt i think that focused
skill enhancement you know people
instead of not everybody should
necessarily be doing a four year ba some
people be better off working
specifically towards a job in an
industry where there's a understanding
in advance that this is what's needed
this is the opening Community College
prepares those kinds of courses so more
focused job oriented training for some
students who are interested in that
might be helpful but this is a long-term
trend and I don't have an easy easy
solution for it
Thank You mr. senator to me Thank You
mr. chairman and I too want to thank
chairman bernanke not just for being
with us today but also for his years of
service and we've had our disagreements
over the years but not without on my
part a great deal of respect for the the
way you've approached this work and the
work that you've done I have a couple of
a few questions I hope would be able to
mow through one has to do with the
efficacy of the quantitative easing and
more specifically there's a number of
very thoughtful folks have done analyses
that suggests that the benefits of the
quantitative easing we've had might be
quite modest and specifically i think
the suggestion has been that
conventional understanding of the
transmission mechanism of the increase
in household net worth to consumer
spending would suggest the very modest
increase the gdp that's resulted from
the pretty significant increase recently
in household net worth even if you
attributed all of that increase to the
fed which is itself a questionable
premise and then but your own previous
testimony i think it was that joint
economic to a question that i asked if i
understood you correctly you acknowledge
that the nature of the impact that
monetary policy tends to have on
economic growth might be more a matter
of timing rather than a net increase so
accommodative policy can accelerate can
move forward economic activity might not
increase economic activity in total so
if the I guess what I'm saying is if if
the magnitude of the benefit has been
very modest and at that it might be just
a shift in timing anyway that would
suggest pretty modest benefits and yet
the cost and the risk keep mounting I in
my view the risks of asset bubbles
mispricing assets the other the risks of
whether or not we'll have an orderly
exit so I guess my question would be
number one how do you quantify the
benefits that have been occurring and
especially near term marginal benefits
going forward and can you and do you
systematically attempt to quantify the
the risks of the
of what you've done yes I'm this very
good question there's a very large
literature academic and within central
bank's trying to figure out how big the
effects are of quantitative easing and
it's quite difficult to know for sure
but the preponderance of the evidence is
that while this is not as powerful a
tool as ordinary monetary policy rate
policy that it does have meaningful
impact on jobs and on the economy in
particular since 2008 where we've had no
ability to move short-term rates and
we've had some periods where we became
you know somewhat more concerned about
deflation we think that QE has provided
an important boost at critical times to
help the economy continue to move
forward so I don't want to overstate it
and again there's a lot of uncertainty
but there's a lot of work on this and
the preponderance of the work suggests
that the effects well not huge are quite
meaningful also in terms of timing it's
true that that no monetary policy can do
very much about the long-term growth
potential of the economy but in a
situation where we're well below that
potential if we can get back to that
potential more quickly that is in that
game that that is enjoyed by the economy
terms of costs and risks we have I've
identified in speeches and other other
other places some of these risks and we
as I said it's in our statement that we
look at this carefully I think the one
that we have paid the most attention to
is financial stability and we have tried
to greatly increase our our vigilance or
monitoring our use of supervisory tools
and the like and as Senator Menendez
actually pointed out though the there's
also risks on both sides because of
course if the economy does very poorly
then that also creates risks to
financial stability because of the
effect on default delinquency and so on
so let me just acknowledge that this is
an issue that that is important one we
believe the first line of defense should
be monitoring supervision regulation
and other similar tools but we do take
into effect take into account sorry the
these costs and risks when we debate our
monetary policy do you attempt to
quantify it or is it all subjective we
we we try to quantify it it's very
difficult of course to know exactly what
the size of the risk is but what we do
is that we do a lot of work both
qualitative and quantitative trying to
measure for example we might be looking
at covenants on on loans and whether or
not those covenants are becoming less
restrictive which is suggestive of more
a poor underwriting for example so we
monitor those kinds of things and we
report those to the FOMC essentially
every meeting so they can understand
where there may be sectors where
financial risks are building and try to
gauge those risks all right thank you I
have other questions but I see my time
is expired nice mr. chairman senator
schumer thank you Miss jam and I want to
thank you as well Chairman Bernanke as
you endure your second marathon in two
days and echo the views of many of my
colleagues in the House and Senate who
thank you for your service during such a
critical period you're quiet but strong
leadership has been instrumental in
keeping our economy from falling into an
abyss and repeating the devastation of a
Great Depression and we are now because
of your leadership on the path towards
turning that economy around my view is
that 2014 and 2015 will be stronger
economically than our present time and
that will be in large part because of
the building blocks that you put into
place even if you're no longer chairman
of the Fed not prejudging anything of
course so here are my questions you've
been as clear as I think you can be that
the timing and pace of any tapering
these are monetary timing and tapering
of your asset purchases will be
dependent on economic and
financial conditions that's logical in
June the committee projected the
economic growth would pick up and coming
quarters but since then economic date
has been mixed we've had decent job
numbers but many signs of weakening
growth we found out that the baseline
for your June outlook was worse than we
first thought first quarter GDP numbers
were revised downward so the economy is
worse than you thought in June but the
markets appear to think that you're
still set to begin tapering in September
so if the economy didn't change were
exactly today as it is today on
September 18th would the Fed be
announcing a moderation in the pace of
its assets and just one subsidiary
question you've often said that asset
purchases will continue until the Fed
sees quote substantial improvement in
the labor market outlook does weakening
day to regarding growth change your
outlook with respect to the strength of
the labour market in other words can
labor markets continue to improve and
relative growth so first about September
18th and then about the labor markets
well the the June FOMC meeting was only
a few weeks ago there been some data
points since then and you say they've
been mixed so I think it's way too early
to make any any judgment will be
obviously reviewing the data and what
we're looking for is a pick up as the
year progresses because our theory of
the case if you will is that one of the
reasons that the economy has been so
slow in the early part of 2013 is
because of fiscal factors it's hard to
judge how long those factors will last
but if if we if the economy begins to
move beyond that point and fiscal
restraint becomes somewhat less
pronounced then we should see as you
suggested yourself a pickup in growth
and so that's what we'll be looking for
it's too early to up to 28 the September
18th deadline of beginning tapering is
not immutable you're going to look at
the data we're going to we're going to
obviously look at the data it's a
committee decision and it's going to
depend on whether we see the improvement
which I described right and second the
second question does the weakening data
regarding growth change or outlook with
respect to the strength of labour
markets yes so we talked about
we specifically set as a goal and
improvement in the outlook for the labor
market as opposed to labor market per se
yeah and what that means is that we want
to see improvement in labor market
indicators but we also have a sense that
improvement will continue and of course
for improvement to continue you need to
have a broader based growth and so of
the three conditions which I described
you know one of them is a pickup in
growth which will be sufficient to
provide continue to improve think we
still could be on the path to labor
markets improving even with this
relatively weak growth in terms of
outlook it's possible I think again it's
only been a few weeks since the June
meeting and I don't think we have new
data okay my second my first question
was about the tapering my second is when
you might end asset purchases altogether
the minutes of your last meeting said
that quote about half of the
participants indicated it would be
likely that it likely would be
appropriate to end asset purchases late
this year yet you yourself said in
guidance that was approved by the
committee based on current projections
you expect asset purchases to end
sometime in the middle of next year when
you currently anticipate unemployment
will be down around seven percent that's
the level of unemployment you say
represents the amount of improvement
that would warrant a moderation and fed
policy do those other members have a
different definition of substantial
improvement in the labor market there
seems to be some disparity between the
other members and you and if you're not
there come next year there's a worry
there or a different view of the likely
path of the labour market do you think
do they think unemployment will be seven
percent of the this year or do they have
different cess mints about the relative
cost and benefit of QE well their
diverse views obviously on this on this
program and in particular people could
see an early wind down because they are
optimistic about the economy or because
they don't think that QE is very
effective I mean a lot of different
reasons why you might have that view let
me just assure you that we have a very
careful discussion at the meeting we
have what's called a go-around where
every person including the non ville
gets to express at for several minutes
their view on policy both current and
prospective and the general scenario
which I described in my press conference
uh is broadly supported by people on the
committee and including both voters and
non-voters good that's good to hear and
gives me a little relief senator coburn
mr. Bernanke I appreciate the service
that you've given our country and we
have nobody to compare you to because
we've never been in the situation we
were in before but I I think basically
you've done some significant work for
the average American and I appreciate it
I have a couple of questions in terms of
your balance with your mandate both in
terms of inflation and employment and
growth one of the things that concerns
me is since 1980 we've changed the way
we measure inflation 20 times and if you
use the same measure of inflation that
we had in 1980 our inflation rate would
be over eight percent right now and the
other thing it concerns me is median
family income in real dollars is the
same as it was in 1989 so if if I had a
criticism of anything you've done in the
last few years it would really go along
and align more with Senator corkers
thoughts is we have we've let you down
the kindergarten of Congress has let you
down by not doing the things to create
the confidence to create the certainty
in the business community that will
allow the significant capital is sitting
on the sidelines to be invested which
would create some of the growth that
you're hoping to do so for that I
apologize but would you care to comment
the sense in your testimony inflations
under control but the average American
over the last 10 years has seen
significant inflow
and in the last few years has seen
significant inflation and the things
that really matter and let me talk about
cost of an education transportation
electricity rents food plus out of what
we've done not intentionally we've
gotten a commodity bubble in many areas
in terms of raw commodities would you
comment on both the changing metrics
that we use for inflation as well as
maybe what we could have done looking
backwards that might have accentuated an
augmented what you've done well on
inflation the inflation statistics are
calculated by the bureau of labor
statistics as you know which is made up
of highly qualified professional
economists there's no partisan influence
and their efforts are always to try to
make the inflation numbers better and
make them more accurate and that's my
sense of what's been happening there in
terms of changes there was a bipartisan
Commission on inflation measurements a
few years ago which concluded that the
official inflation number is overstated
not understated inflation and so some of
the changes they recommend it have been
included so there's a distinction
between prices being high and prices
being rising if it's true that gas
prices and food prices all these prices
relative to people's wages wages aren't
going up much that's right so they talk
to living this going up it isn't going
up it's it's high it's not going up in
other words real wages are going down
real wages have been going down because
even though inflation is very low wages
have been growing slower than inflation
so so discretionary income has decreased
so consumer spending is not rising at
the rate of which you would like to see
it that's that's true but that's not an
issue of inflation that's an issue of
real living standards and it has to do
with the productivity the economy and
the distribution of income and the Fed
really can't do a whole lot about that
so I guess I would just respectfully
disagree that inflation is badly under
measured I think they're professionals
are doing as good a job as they can to
measure inflation and if you look at a
lot of prices
is an including rents food gasoline and
so on again while they may be high
they're not much different from they
were a year ago and that's that's what
inflation is about as a rate of change
over time in terms of what Congress
could do I mean I think you know I can
only go so far in in recommending but I
do think that an attempt to focus the
budget consolidation efforts more on the
longer term I agree would have been a
more productive way rather than putting
so much of the tax increases and
spending cuts in a front-loaded way
would have been more helpful that would
be one suggestion so if in fact Congress
had behaved appropriately and helped
create a certainty in the long term
especially with our entitlement programs
but also in terms of some of the ways
the effectiveness of some of the things
you've done with monetary policy might
have been greater certainly Thank You
senator bro Thank You mr. chairman
German a key thank you for your service
as others have done and we all mean that
and thank you for the new rules on
capital standards that you have issued
with OCC and FDIC I I urge you to hold
fast on them when the megabanks fight to
weaken those standards and I hope that
you will do that I some financial
institutions are argue as as we have
discussed it we should not get out ahead
of Europe in our financial regulation on
Monday governor Tarullo said and i want
to quote at some length i think it's
very dangerous that some have tried to
characterize basel agreements as the
ceiling not the floor so for us in the
united states those of us who are
charged with financial stability of the
united states need to make the judgment
as to what levels of capital will most
ensure financial stability in the
country without unduly affecting the
flow of credit even since the
publication of our ever since
publication of our proposed reg I've had
calls from my counterparts around the
world German to roll says that's really
interesting they're saying tell me the
reasoning on this how you're thinking
about it explain to me more why you
think three percent is inadequate then
quote when I hear governors rolls saying
is that we should do what we think is
best for
our financial stability and if we lead
by example the rest of the world will
follow do you agree with Governor
Tarullo I certainly agree with the first
part which is that Basel 3 is a floor
it's not a ceiling it's a it's what it's
really a least common denominator
because these agreements are made
essentially by unanimous consensus and
therefore if there are a few countries
that are very resistant for whatever
reason you know that that makes it
tougher to get the higher standard so we
view the limit as a floor and we were
prepared to do whatever additional steps
are needed in order to make our
financial system safe I don't know
whether all countries will follow us but
there are other countries as what's alan
comes to mind UK that have thought hard
about this and have made additional take
taken additional steps to strengthen
their banking systems and we do have a
leadership position and I hope that will
happen but I don't think it will be
universal I think that we will see
different responses from different
country but the most important countries
with financial systems will follow as
governor Tarullo suggest I don't know
whether they'll follow the exact same
things but they're all they've all got
the same the key financial centers which
recognize how important banks are to
their economy but also the fact that in
some cases the banks are bigger than
their economy recognize that it's very
important to have stability and they
have been particularly willing to
consider additional status so we should
not shrink from doing the right thing
for stability of our country because
some mega banks say that we will be an
outlier in other countries won't follow
agree well they may or may or may not
follow some will but whether they do or
not I do agree that we should do
whatever we need to do to make sure that
the US financial system is is safe let
me ask thank you let me ask another
question it's it's bank earnings season
again as you know and it's no surprise
that mega banks are doing quite well yet
they continue to claim that regulations
new regulations impending regulations
are killing them
these Financial Times said here's the
problem banks have spent a lot of time
energy and money warning of the
potential ill effects of ramping up
regulation but since the crisis
international regulators have kept
demanding more capital including a
surcharge for the bigger banks as you
said lenders have doubled their capital
levels as a result hitting the new Basel
three targets six years early in some
case and yet Financial Times asked where
are the ill effects the best of them
continued to set new prophet records
with every earning season warming's of
calamity look more and more hollow
unquote the debate about the feds new
proposed supplementary leverage ratio
reminds me that when we think about
costs we as policymakers regulators and
elected officials when we think about
costs and benefits industry wants us
only to think about cost to them steel
companies dumped waste into our rivers
and then they argue that it will be
costly to clean it up it's been a bets a
higher human cost of the miners and the
children who get sick from the pollution
it passes more health care costs onto
our society clearly as they fail to
internalize those costs those who
believe in a society with rules
understand that auto safety might cost
car companies a little bit more for
airbags and seatbelts and other safety
features but these protections save
lives the same with financial rules they
might cost bank executives a little bit
more and smaller bonuses and maybe even
in dividends but they'll help prevent a
repeat of what we had five years ago
where the costs obviously were shifted
to the broad public in retirement
savings and lost jobs in every way
imaginable and certainly people's lost
homes if these are the costs of a safer
financial system aren't they worth it
the the crisis was an enormous waste of
resources and the it's unsafe practices
by large financial institutions pose a
risk not just to themselves but to the
rest of society and in setting policy we
should look at the social costs and not
just the cost to the to the firm's and
that's what we're attempting to do and
if it means the bonuses are a little
smaller
and the dividends are a little less and
the earnings reports of the banks aren't
quite up to what they were this quarter
which was pretty pretty lucrative
quarter for them that's a price we
should pay I think society from a cost
point of view I think what we should be
looking at is whether there's any effect
on credit availability things of that
sort that affect our economy more
broadly but I certainly agree that again
given the enormous cost of the crisis
that strong measures to prevent a repeat
are obviously well justified on a cost
concerns at these higher capital
standards will result in less credit
available I don't think so no I'm not
concerned about it we've you know we've
done some analysis of that and there's
not much evidence of that there's not
really much downside if you said that
higher capital that you said that
biggest potential problem with rules is
does it mean less credit available if it
doesn't mean less credit available
there's no real downside for strong
capital standard the only downside I can
think of is that is that credit flows
may find you know if banks are finding
themselves finding very costly to make
loans then credit may start flowing
through other less regulated channels
and those have to be monitored but we're
not we're not you're not implying at all
that we're there yet even close to that
situation with capital standards no
we're not there yet but we have to watch
the shadow banking system in other parts
of the system to make sure that risks
are not being off loaded into other
parts of the financial system thank you
understand thank you for generosity of
time and you senator hurt our color
Thank You mr. chairman and I certainly
appreciate the questioning of the
senator Brown and Chairman Bernanke
thank you for being here and taking time
because I was pleased to hear that she's
a basil through is the floor and in the
question I think you answered the
question I was going to ask you to give
me some insight what wife why we came to
basal three as opposed to a former FDIC
chair who wants that percentage should
be closer to eight percent we have
legislation around here that wants it a
size fifteen percent so I was looking
for some insight as to where we came to
those basal three capital rates
and it appears the answer may be risk
unless you have more to add to it well
we are we have a program for building up
capital and I described part of it which
was the Basel 3 itself which triples the
amount of high-quality capital then the
surcharges then the higher leverage
ratio and in addition we were looking at
things like capital charges for
wholesale funding if firms rely on on
less reliable wholesale funding and
discussed also the possibility of
requiring large firms to have unsecured
senior debt in their capital structure
which could also provide some buffer in
the event of the firm fail so we are in
a variety of ways trying to build up the
buffer that these large firms have yes
let me change the topic real quick here
on 22 housing Wall Street Journal you
recently had a article on the city of
Las Vegas and the difficulty of moving
homes we've had 300,000 people in Las
Vegas received foreclosure notices not
before closed down but received notices
over fifty percent of the homes are
under water and I know you've played an
important role in trying to reverse this
situation what are we doing wrong and
what can we do what can we do as a
congress to help move and change the
situation we have not only in nevada but
Arizona Florida some of these other
states hmm well as I was saying earlier
I think they're from Congress's point of
view that getting the mortgage finance
system you know working better in terms
of reforming Fannie and Freddie and
helping to clarify the rules some of
that is on us as regulators to do that
so that there's greater access to credit
and more people can buy homes because
ultimately the solution is to find a
demand side for the market you know so
that the demand for homes will support
prices and and and help us get out of
this housing problem we have I wasn't
here earlier in the discussion of the
reforms for Fannie and Freddie have
signed on to the bill here in the Senate
side I know the house rolled out
yesterday do you have a preference I
think it's very important that with the
Congress move forward on this and I
think it's time to do that your insight
on a secondary market or government
involvement in mortgage securities I
think I think a key issue is going to be
not so much making mortgage is cheaper
but rather making sure that there is
some kind of backstop or protection for
situations where the financial markets
are in distress like they were recently
and then the question is the government
is one way to do that there may be other
ways to do that but if the government is
involved i think it would be very
important to make sure first of all
though the government is appropriately
compensated for whatever insurance or
backing it provides and secondly that
firms that are securitizing hold enough
capital again to protect the taxpayer
from losses if that's done I think that
would be those will be very helpful and
if you come to a solution that involves
a government role let me talk about
winter to the topic is I don't have a
lot of time it sorry to jump around so
much but gold prices you know we had
gold prices almost two thousand dollars
an ounce it's dropped about six hundred
dollars an ounce trading I think today
around 12 75 somewhere around there give
any insight on why this volatility what
quantitative easing would have what
long-term impact it will have as you
ratchet back the gold is an unusual
asset it's it's an asset that people
hold as sort of disaster insurance they
want you know they feel if things go
really badly wrong at least they will
you know they'll have some gold in their
portfolio is that an accurate sorry is
that an accurate feeling it's not all
that accurate I mean for example a lot
of people hold gold is an inflation
hedge but the movements of gold prices
don't predict inflation very well
actually but anyway the perception is
that by holding gold you're you're
having you have a hard asset that you'll
be protected it will protect you in case
of some kind of major problem and I
suppose that one reason that gold prices
are lower is that people are less
learned about extreme outcomes either
you know particularly negative outcomes
and therefore they feel less need for
whatever protection golda for you
believe it's an indication perhaps
psychologically the feel the direction
of the economy for investors I think
psychologically it you know what the
goal price going down is not necessarily
a bad thing from that perspective it's
just people have some somewhat more
confidence and are less concerned about
really bad outcomes but let me just end
by saying that nobody really understands
gold prices and I don't pretend to
really understand them either Thank You
mr. chairman thank you very much senator
Warren Thank You mr. chairman and
Chairman Bernanke thank you for all your
service during very hard times I still
want to ask about some other risks to
the economy you know the biggest banks
in the country have reported huge
profits over the last couple of years
but just this week they reported some
staggering numbers Wells Fargo's profits
jumped nineteen percent from last year
JPMorgan Chase profits jump thirty one
percent and citigroup's profits jumped
forty-two percent now some reports have
indicated that a big part of those
profits have come from the bank's
trading activity in other words are not
from boring banking but from trading on
Wall Street and elsewhere so are you
concerned that these biggest banks are
loading up on big risks again or is
there another explanation for this spike
in profits well let me just say that we
are quite aware of these portfolios and
we are addressing them in least two ways
or more than two really but one of them
is that we have just finalized new
capital requirements that data that
banks have to hold against these assets
for sale these securities which should
provide protection we have done stress
tests where we assume that a December
2008 type of financial shock hits and so
there's a huge drop in asset values and
we have stress tested the banks you know
again to see do they have enough capital
cover protect themselves against big
losses in their in their Security's
books the other thing is of course you
know is that we are working hard with
our colleagues to put the vocal rule
into place and that will restrict
proprietary trading let me just say that
mr. chairman the question I'm trying to
ask about is whether this indicates
they're loading up on a risk and I very
much appreciate that what you're asking
you're telling me about are the ways
we're trying to regulate the risk when
the banks take it on maybe I could ask
this slightly differently and that is
yesterday Secretary of Treasury Jack Lew
said and I want to get the quote right
if we get to the end of this year and we
cannot with an honest straight face say
that we have ended too big to fail we're
going to have to look at other options
do you agree with the secretary of the
Treasury uh I don't know about the
timing maybe I take another year from
now but I've said to you in an earlier
hearing that you know there is a
strategy dodd-frank lays out a strategy
Basel 3 provides additional support
through capital etc but if those things
do not make us comfortable about the
status of these largest firms yes I do
think additional steps would be
appropriate then we need to look at
other steps as you know I've introduced
along with Senator McCain senator
Cantwell senator King a glass steagle
bill another tool in the toolbox to deal
with too big to fail but I I think at
least now we've got some time on this
the secretary of the Treasury says by
the end of the year you say maybe you're
longer but we've got to keep this one
under under examination fair enough yes
I think we obviously want to look at all
tools I think that there's probably more
scope for capital yeah if if we're not
comfortable with the status of these
firms good and fair enough on that I
want to ask you as you know the Federal
Reserve in the LCC announced last
January that they were stopping their
investigation into the systemic
foreclosure fraud
that you'd reached a settlement with the
largest mortgage servicers in the
country and just last week the OCC
announced that 52,000 48 people just in
Massachusetts received checks so far
under this settlement and it was an
aggregate total of 41 million dollars in
compensation or about eight hundred
dollars of family now that's eight
hundred dollars of family in a state
Massachusetts where the median home
income is 324,000 five hundred dollars
I'll do the math for you that's about
two-tenths of one percent of the
purchase price of the average home in
the Commonwealth of Massachusetts now
it's my job to look out for families in
Massachusetts including helping them get
basic information about whether
settlements made on their behalf by the
government are fair and to do that six
months ago I started asking for basic
documents about the investigation and to
see what the foreclosure fraud
investigation had uncovered how many
people had lost their chance to save
their home just really how bad the
damage was so far the Fed in the OCC
have disclosed very little of what I've
asked for so the question I have is how
the people I represent in Massachusetts
who believe they were cheated or the
four million people who receive checks
around the country how they know that
the payments they're receiving our fair
if the Fed and the OCC won't disclose
details about what they uncovered in the
investigation well as you know we we
stopped the investigation well before
all 4.2 million borrowers were analyzed
so we don't have that information for
everybody but we do have it for some
folks and we are looking to see if we
can find a way to get that information
to the individuals who do head who did
for whose files were evaluated by the
independent consultants
so so we're talking about getting that
information to them and releasing more
information about what you did find in
the aggregate yes we hope to have a
report on this whole thing within the
next couple of months good that will lay
out basically all the information we
have we some of the things that you've
requested frankly we just didn't collect
or you know whatever but we will try to
provide as much transparency as we can I
would be very grateful for that mr.
chairman you know my concerns in this
area generally that if the regulators
are not aggressive enough if they don't
require admission of guilt if they never
take large financial institutions to
trial then the resulting settlements are
too weak and so I know you appreciate
that a slap on the risk is not enough
and if the OCC and the Fed are confident
that these are good settlements I think
it helps everyone if the information is
out there so thank you mr. chairman
absolutely i'd like to add that of
course the people who receive checks
have not yielded their legal rights and
they could pursue this further they were
and i hope that by revealing this
information they will be able to better
evaluate whether or not that's
appropriate for them Thank You senator
Crapo has a brief statement to make yes
thank you mr. Chairman I have a number
of additional questions but we're coming
up against a vote right away so Chairman
Bernanke if it's a okay with you and
with the Chairman I will submit these
questions to you and ask you to respond
later I had the questions that I have
among others are some further inquiries
about the short term interest rate
policy at the bank the actions right now
at the eff sock the financial stability
Oversight Council in particular in
relationship to non-bank systemically
important financial institutions and as
you might guess on GSE reform I would
love to get some further information
from your perspective on that but I will
submit those questions mr. chairman in
light of the fact that we do have a vote
pending thank you Chairman Bernanke I
want to thank you for your
extraordinary service to our nation and
I want to thank you for your testimony
this hearing is adjourned
this is they're watching they're
watching